>> Laura: RACE WAS FRONT AND
CENTER ON THE RACE LAST NIGHT
AND PERMEATED THE MEDIA SPIN
AFTERWARDS.
CANDACE OWENS, FOUNDER OF THE
BLEXIT MOVEMENT AND AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK "BLACKOUT."
2020 CANDIDATES, THEY'RE OFTEN
IN MY MIND FALSELY ACCUSING
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF BEING RACIST.
CANDIDATES LIKE BUTTIGEIG ARE
INCREASINGLY APPLYING THAT LABEL
TO ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT PEOPLE
COULD SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS IMMIGRATION POLICIES ARE
RACIST?
>> ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS THIS IS
SUPPORTING RACISM.
[SPEAKING SPAN HERB]
>> Laura: THE MEDIA TOOK IT A
STEP FURTHER SUGGESTING HILLARY
CLINTON WAS RIGHT TO CALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS DEPLORE
SUPPORTERS DEPLOABL
SUPPORTERS DEPLODEL
SUPPORTERS DEPLODEPLORABLES.
>> IF THEY'RE SUPPORTING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND WHAT HE'S
DOING IS RACISM, WHAT DO YOU SAY
ABOUT THE FOLKS CHEERING HIM ON.
>> IT'S A GREAT POINT OR COMMENT
ABOUT BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
IT TURNS OUT SHE WAS DEAD ON.
>> Laura: AT LEAST EVERYONE IS
BEING HONEST THE WAY THEY FEEL.
I WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE IT OUT
THERE.
THEY WANT TO CALL IT
DEPLORABLES.
ARE THEY GOING TOO FAR HERE?
>> I THINK THIS IS EINSTEIN'S
DEFINITION OF INSANITY, DOING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULTS.
I DON'T SEE HOW THEY COULD BE
FALLING INTO THIS TRAP AGAIN.
THEY'RE SAYING I'M A RACIST.
I SUPPORT TRUMP, I'M A BLACK
AMERICA.
THEY SAY I WANT TO SEE A SOCIETY
COME TOGETHER THAT I CAN'T LIVE
IN.
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S NOT
INSULTING TO AMERICANS BUT IT
REQUIRES NO INTELLECTUAL DEPTHS.
TRY TO CONSIDER WHAT HAPPEN IN
2016 AND LEARN TO WHAT HAPPENED
IN 2016 BUT THEY CAN'T, THEY'RE
TOO ARROGANT.
>> MAYOR PETE, MONIQUE,
SOMETIMES HAS A MODERATE
APPROACH WITH THE WAY HE DEBATES
AND SPEAKS.
HE'S ATTRACTIVE IN MANY WAYS TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT SURPRISED ME COMING FROM
HIM.
COMING FROM SOUTH BEND,
INTERESTING COMMUNITY, VERY
DIVERSE.
BUT I NEVER THINK IT'S A WINNING
THING TO ATTACK AMERICANS.
ATTACK TRUMP, GO AT IT.
BUT ATTACK AMERICANS, THAT'S --
I THINK THAT'S A NO-NO.
>> HE WASN'T ATTACKING
AMERICANS.
HE WAS ATTACKING -- HE WAS
ATTACKING A POINT OF VIEW.
HE SAID IF YOU'RE SUPPORTING A
RACIST POLICY, YOU'RE A RACIST.
IF YOU SUPPORT A POLICY THAT
SAYS GO OUT ON THE STREET AND
HIT EVERY FIFTH PERSON WITH
BLOND HAIR NAMED LAURA, YOU
PROBABLY ARE --
>> Laura: YOU LOST ME.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO ATTACK EVERY
BLOND HAIRED PERSON NAMED LAURA.
IF YOU'RE SUPPORTING IMMIGRATION
POLICIES THAT ARE RACIST, THEN
YOU, TOO, ARE RACIST BECAUSE YOU
SUPPORT RACIST THINGS.
>> HE DIDN'T SAY THE WORD
"POLICY," THOUGH.
>> YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE ANSWER.
>> I LISTENED TO THE ANSWER.
HE SAID YOU'RE A PERSON THAT
SUPPORTS TRUMP, NOT A POLICY.
>> I COULD ASK YOU WHAT COLOR
THE SKY IS OR --
>> YOU'RE PUTTING WORD IN HIS
MOUTH.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> BUT, AGAIN --
>> DEFENDING HIM.
>> Laura: THIS IS DONALD TRUMP
TODAY -- I THINK IT'S TODAY.
IT MIGHT BE YESTERDAY, I'M
LOSING TRACK OF TIME.
HE SAID WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF
IMMIGRATION.
JARED KUSHNER HAS A 600-PAGE
PLAN ON THE WAY TO CAPITOL HILL
OR ALREADY THERE WHICH I THINK
WILL INCLUDE HANDLING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, TRYING TO COME
TOGETHER ON SOME COMPROMISE.
IF THAT'S RACIST, BOY, WE ARE IN
TROUBLE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S A BIG, BIG DEAL.
IF THEY'RE WORKING ON THAT,
WHICH THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
FOR EIGHT MONTHS, AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING, THIS IS RACIST, THEN
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO MAKE ANY
PROGRESS ON ANYTHING.
>> IS IT KIND OF -- IF IT'S A
FIFTH, WE'D ALL BE DRUNK?
ARE WE REALLY IN THE THIRD YEAR
IN IF THIS IS REALLY HAPPENING
>> Laura: WHAT DID OBAMA DO ON
THE BORDER?
HE DEPORTED MORE PEOPLE THAN
TRUMP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: THEN BARACK OBAMA IS A
RACIST UNDER THAT DYNAMIC.
>> THAT MAKES HIM A PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK HE'S A
RACIST.
>> WE'RE AGREEING THAT TRUMP IS
A PRESIDENT.
>> WE ARE AGREEING THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD FOLLOW THE LAW.
>> NOT BE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
WE AGREE ON THAT.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
AGREE.
THEY WANT TO LEGALIZE ALL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> I'M A DEMOCRAT.
>> YOU AND I AGREE ON THAT.
>> Laura: LADIES, PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS CREATING THE SPACE, BUT
COREY BOOKER WANTS TO CREATE THE
RACE FOR US.
>> RACISM EXISTS, THE QUESTION
IS WHO ISN'T A RACIST, IT'S WHO
ISN'T DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
RACISM.
IF I'M PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, WE WILL CREATE AN OFFICE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO DEAL WITH
THE POLICY OF WHITE SUPREMACY
AND HATE CRIMES.
>> Laura: THE MOON SHOT?
>> ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS TO BE
PRESIDENT.
BERNIE SANDERS WANTS TO BE
COREY BOOKER DOES NOT WISH TO BE
PRESIDENT.
HE'S OUT HERE FOR FAME AND
MOMENTS.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN THIS PERSON.
HE'S A NARCISSIST AT ITS CORE.
HE'S NOT MEANT TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
I'M SPARTACUS IN CONGRESS.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT COREY BOOKER.
FOR HIM TO SAY RACE FORCE IS A
PART OF HIS PROGRAMMING.
HE LOVES ATTENTION.
HE LOVES THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
HIM.
AND NO ONE ON THE LEFT OR RIGHT
SHOULD BE TAKING HIM PERSONAL
SERIOUSLY.
>> Laura: WANTED TO PUNCH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE FACE.
>> IS THAT BECAUSE YOU MET HIM
YOU KNOW WHAT HE WANTS.
>> I'M SAYING --
>> THE MENTAL DETERMINATION OF
WHAT HE WANTS.
I'VE MET HIM.
I TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD.
>> JUST CALLED ME RACIST FIVE
SECONDS AGO.
>> COREY BOOKER.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> LISTENING TO YOUR LOGIC.
>> COREY BOOKER WAS SPEAKING
ABOUT A REAL ISSUE, WHITE
SUPREMACY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS 15 MINUTES
FROM NOW GO DOWN MY TIMELINE AND
YOU'LL UNDERSTAND THE VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO
IS CANDACE, SOMEONE WHO IS YOU,
AND SOMEONE -- [INDISCERNIBLE]
BUT ARE THEY SAYING GET A NOOSE.
ARE THEY SAYING --
>> THEY'RE SAYING GET CANCER.
GET CANCER COMES BACK.
>> THAT'S NOT RACISM, RIGHT?
>> IT'S --
>> WHEN THERE'S A FALLACIOUS
ARGUMENT.
>> IT'S A --
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO KNOW --
>> YOU MADE THAT POINT CLEAR.
>> YOU HAVE TO KNOW SOMEBODY TO
KNOW WHAT THEY WANT.
>> WHY ARE YOU COMMENTING ON
SFLUFRP.
>> I ASKED IF YOU KNEW HIM.
>> I ASKED YOU -- I AM ALLOWED
TO COMMENT ON HIM.
>> I DIDN'T TAKE BACK YOUR
COMMENT.
I SAID IT'S NOT --
>> WE ALL COMMENT ON --
>> THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
>> I MEAN --
>> THAT'S A RULE.
>> I COMMENT ON WHAT PEOPLE SAY.
AND WHAT THEY DO.
I DON'T COMMENT ABOUT THEIR
INTENTIONS.
>> Laura: HOLD ON.
>> OH, COME ON.
>> BECAUSE HOW DO I KNOW.
>> YOU COMMENT ON WHAT TRUMP
WANTS.
>> Laura
.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT MAN
WANTS.
>> Laura: GUYS, WE CAN'T.
>> YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU KNOW
HIM.
>> Laura: WE'VE GOT TO KNOW.
HE WANTS PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DELIVERING.
WE COMMENT ALL THE TIME THAT WE
HAVEN'T MET.
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE DO.
AS YOU HISTORIANS WRITE ABOUT --
>> IT'S THE ULTIMATE --
>> IT'S THE ULTIMATE POLICY TO
COMMENT ON.
>> Laura: WHY ARE YOU ON THIS
SHOW?
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, I GOT TO
GO, WE'RE GOING TO GET CUT OFF,
GUYS.
WE'VE GOT TO GO.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE BARACK OBAMA
IS A RACIST.